so let's talk about what to eat after
you have your gallbladder removed so the
first thing you want to try to
understand is why you had the
gallbladder out in the first place so a
couple things will cause gallbladder
problems number one estrogen that could
be from birth control pills let's say
you were pregnant let's say you are
taking hormone replacement therapy etc
number two high levels of insulin will
do that so a highly refined carbohydrate
diet a lot of junk food a lot of sugar
and also certain side effects from
medications will create gall stones and
the destruction of the gall bladder so
whatever you did that could have created
that you want to clean that up so just
because you had a gallbladder out and
now you're able to eat certain foods
that you didn't eat before and they're
unhealthy you don't want to continue to
do that simply because the gall bladder
problem was just a symptom of a bigger
problem so you really want to clean up
your diet and that's what I'm gonna
recommend right here especially if you
don't have a gallbladder because you
have certain weaknesses that you're
gonna have to compensate for the biggest
thing is this so when they remove the
gallbladder they remove the storage
pouch for bile bile helps you dissolve
the fat to help you extract certain
nutrients from the fat without that and
I'm talking about the storage a sack and
the concentration of the bile
now you are going to have a deficiency
in bile because you no longer can store
it and one point about that is that when
you don't have the gallbladder you don't
have the ability to concentrate the bile
in the gallbladder
you're basically concentrating bile up
to 20 times not 20% 20x so that bile is
so super concentrated it doesn't take
much to be able to create the full
digestive effect that you need so you
don't have this concentration anymore
and bile
so you're going to have this diluted
bile in smaller amounts so eventually
you end up with deficiencies in vitamin
A that's the eyes sinuses the immune
system vitamin D the bone vitamin
the heart even your hair needs vitamin E
vitamin K that's one thing
number two lower amounts of money
omega-3 fatty acids so that's really
important in heart and vision and brain
cognitive function mood so if you can't
absorb these it doesn't help to take
more of them because you're not
processing or breaking it down so what
does that mean it means that you should
probably take some purified bile salts I
put a link down below for more
information on what I would recommend
for that now as far as the symptoms that
can occur after they remove the
gallbladder these are some side effects
but I think if you eat correctly and you
support what you're missing I think you
can really minimize these effects right
here but number one gastritis and acid
reflux diarrhea because what's happening
is the liver is making bile and it's
trickling down this little duct into the
small intestine even when you're not
eating so it's just kind of constantly
draining and bile is a lubricant for the
colon so it's going to create a laxative
effect but also you could have
constipation as well depending on what's
happening a lot of times when they
remove the gallbladder you develop scar
tissue in there and then that could have
struck the bile even more and then you
have even more of a deficiency but if
you don't have the file you can
constipate it because there's no
lubrication so you can have either one
another symptom is anal leakage another
one is abdominal pain and realize the
microbes in your gut help you recycle
bile 90% of the bile is recycled so if
you have any problems with your micro
bacteria down here that can be another
reason why you're suffering over here in
the production of bile because they're
both connected okay gas fat
malabsorption we talked about that and
even stones in the liver and I'm talking
about developing stones in the duct that
comes right out of the liver right here
that's a potential because the stones
actually are caused by a deficiency in
bile
so anyway that's one possibility right
there
all right what would you eat number one
you don't want to do necessarily a
low-fat diet why because it's the fat
that triggers the bile release so the
lesser amount of fat that you eat the
lesser bile production but we don't want
to do too much because we don't want to
overload the system because you only
have a certain amount of bile and so if
you actually have too much fat you're
just gonna strain the whole system
because you don't have enough file to
digest that fat so a moderate amount of
fat not a low fat diet not a high fat a
moderate amount of fat moderate amount
of protein and low carbs why because
it's high insulin that causes the
problem the first place okay high
insulin will deplete your bile reserve
higher amounts of vegetables would be
very very beneficial and the more bitter
a vegetable is that better apple cider
vinegar will help you increase the flow
of bile through these ducts through here
fermented vegetables are very very
beneficial why because they add the
prebiotic which is a the fiber that
feeds the microbes to actually grow that
way you'll get better recycling with
your bile and it also has a probiotic
effect it has friendly bacteria to give
you more bacteria to take the stress off
this recycling mechanism right here so
fermented vegetables are really good big
salads are very very beneficial
you can even steam some vegetables as
well and the last thing you want to do
is make sure you do not stuff yourself
do not eat so much food that you're
constantly bloated all the time you're
probably just gonna have to be very
aware on what you eat and to make sure
you don't overdo it because that's gonna
put a big strain on this whole mechanism
and shut down the bio even more and
create more pain and more problem
alright thanks for watching so if you
want more knowledge on how to create a
healthy body subscribe now and get daily
notifications daily notifications that
sounds weird well I'll just remind you
on a daily basis how about that